[Music]
we are lady parts
here's a little something we thought you
might like
that is me 26 capricorn finishing a phd
in
microbiology
and this is lady parts a confused mix of
hash anthems and
sour girl power our sound is thin we
need something more
we need lead guitarist we don't need a
wanky self-indulgent guitar soloist
this decided who would have thought that
our orbits were soon to collide
you you went to son abigail's primary
school you play guitar in the talent
show
you got expelled for selling school
furniture very lit his eye
play something play something someday i
don't perform
my nerfy disposition induces diary and
vomiting
ew i vowed i would never perform again
but lady parts had other plans she's our
[Music]
it guitarist kind of like therapy but
with a lot of screaming
[Music]
you've got a problem with my lyrics you
could do less
more yay
[Applause]
to our newest band number a delightful
freak show
and our great new friend am i really
that bad
you're that good
we're sisters our music is about
representation
it's about being hurt
[Music]
you're in a punk band yes ma and you
haven't been
or
this is us buy us for us
[Music]
talk to me i have visions
i write them down and people pay to read
them
scott had a history of becoming unstuck
to reality where'd you go
he called it being gone
come back
i'm on a bull hunt what's a bull hunt
like a scavenger hunt scott and his
brother made up when they were kids
mrs landon i just thought i'd give it
one more try in person
scott's unpublished words need to be
collected
examine you're never going to see his
papers
she won't let them go i'll get those
papers for you
[Music]
scotland's books changing
do you remember that night you asked if
i was crazy
i believed in it that's how strong his
imagination is
there's a place i'll take you there
what is this where are
you we all the riddles find all the
clues
and you get a prize where we went today
was it real
or was it my imagination
[Music]
i said doctor
mr empty
would you tell me what's wrong with
me he's gone
and he keeps pushing me towards
[Music]
was it real or was it my imagination
[Music]
[Music]
once upon a time
[Music]
bad people ruled the earth
they were greedy and self-destructive
so nature made everyone sick
[Music]
excuse me are you a doctor
and then a miracle happened
they called them hybrids you're kind
it's your job to live a full life
but some bad people are still out there
gus
if i hear a voice i will run
if i see a human i will hide
we have reason to believe that you are
harboring an animal child
it's me little freak
thank you
where's colorado what's in colorado i
heard there's a safe place for kids like
me
if you go out there alone they'll have
your head by morning
[Music]
i got you
guys like me aren't good for kids like
you
how do you know most people hate kids
like me
rusty the last men have made it their
mission to eliminate hybrids
but we've made it ours to protect them
this new world
is all about survival no matter the cost
what are you doing with him
i did what i had to to survive
if there's anyone out there like me i
need to find them
that little dude's got hope coming out
every poor
[Applause]
[Music]
can anyone hear me this is what the end
of humanity looks like
they came to earth six months ago they
looked just like us
the girl they found on the ship why did
they keep her alive
i'm your dad i'm supposed to keep you
safe
and i can't protect you
they killed my wife and my son they're
gonna wipe us out
none of us are safe i didn't ask for
this
this is our only opportunity to defeat
them
[Music]
the aliens trust you you can get close
to them
you can kill them all
[Music]
i know how their race started they were
coming
home
[Music]
home or abroad wherever you go my
patent-pending medicine will free you
from
troublesome behaviors and distracting
wants the life you should be leading
can finally begin
i moved halfway across the world
and i feel i don't know the man i'm
married at all
here i am in tundia
i know no one
i got married today congratulations
i build the wall around us protect you
from the monsters
what if i'm the monster
dungeon is everything all at once
it is everywhere and noah
i was having a dream does it feel
like a scene
[Music]
can we have some fun
can you see it your new world
do you long to be shiny
me
[Music]
the camera makes love to you
passionately
somebody needs to
[Music]
you signed for me father indeed i did
olivia druzilla have you restored power
to the senate yet i'm trying
father are you or have you secretly
fallen in love with your power
but to restore the republic we first
have to destroy it
i know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart i am smart
i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
why me i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this low-key
period
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
bye is adorable
that you think you could possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
mom dad
i'm gay you are literally dating
the most gorgeous guy at creekwood well
i mean beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
yeah behold benji [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey so maybe we should probably talk
about what we're going to tell everyone
i want to tell people i'm ready
[Music]
no more hiding who i am
everyone thinks coming out is easy these
days but it's not
my own moms really look at me between my
dad getting engaged and veronica getting
pregnant
hi guys i wanted to figure out where i
fit here did you figure it out
sorry i'm late queens before peens
say the word and i will ditch these gays
like a corporation after pride month
even as the woods came sometimes i come
out here to escape the badness of my
apartment
mom did you take your medication what
are you escaping
i just need to talk virgin to virgin i'm
terrified to have sex for the first time
if you're with the right person
it doesn't matter oh and grooming is no
longer just for the ladies so if
downtown felix looks anything like
uptown felix
tidy up what is the perfect level of gay
that will keep everyone happy
i'm too gay to be in the locker rooms
but i'm not gay enough for benjing his
friends
tell me that you support me it's a lot
for me to wrap my head around
do you think you're a will he's my son
and it's who he is
i have to if i didn't have you
[Music]
you should be around people who want you
to be you
be undeniable let's go
[Music]
maybe one day i can inspire someone to
be themselves
damn gay victor has way bigger balls
than straight victor
love victor
this is going too far
pellegrini kidnapped my son
he'll pay for that
recognize him of course i do the
up the police are looking for assange
the most wanted man in france this
evening
what now we disappeared
i would really love to help but i think
you're wasting your time the sun won't
be bad
i was framed
and i'm not guilty the foundation was
robbed but we refused to be intimidated
do you think the uplight show he uploads
the spectacle
he'll come right to us
can't screw this up
no lies no more [ __ ]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
what's the new plan
what are you trying to tell me
listen carefully got it okay i got it
try cold water
the coffee stand on your shirt try cold
water
i'm hot like 95 fahrenheit on the summer
night tight spot where bodies ride
rats straight from water drops in the
street singing little kids scared cops
with red dots philosophical gangster
with violent priors
throwing back like black and white tvs
with pliers leaning on broke down cars
with flat tires flash eyeing on anybody
trying on them
nothing but magic
it's hard being a reporter but if it
were easy everyone would want to do it
right
right
afternoon comrades who are you guys
vigilantes for truth we're very
entrepreneurial
i'm in high school now okay things are
gonna be different i don't want them to
be different
you have to start doing some normal kid
stuff oh my god
are those dead
i thought i'd already written the most
important story of my life
but this was bigger
this town there are all sorts of rules
you got to play by
[Music]
i think something in erie harbor is
making people sick and they've been
covering this up for years
messages
oh my god and i ain't got nothing to say
if we don't figure out what they're
covering up everyone in this town could
be in danger
we're not going to let that happen
seriously hilby you're like some old
person reddit feed
like inside my house does something
happen somewhere
this could be how we find richie he saw
something and that's why he got taken
baby criminal trespassing
on a school night but in a purposeful
way
for a good cause
[Music]
we have no idea what these people are
capable of
the hardest stories to cover are the
ones you care most about
we're young but we are not stupid
they cannot stop her from speaking the
truth
[Music]
it's about a woman who keeps playing
perfect housewife
[Music]
hey where's our breakfast you're not
supposed to have favorites
kevin's my husband yeah babe can you go
see if my package is here yet
can't you do it i'm in the middle of
something
then one day she realizes what she wants
whoa miss hercules over here
is that blood it doesn't mean you get to
be moody you already use that excuse
once this month
you got a special occasion you want to
look nice for i am cnnx
what i missed the last 15 years she
wasted the life on this terrible
marriage
the money's gone kevin drained the
account you ever think about maybe
trying to have just a little bit of fun
you can get in trouble for that you're
having trouble you did it
what the hell lady i'm not sorry she has
this brilliant plan
good for you honey kevin and allison
together forever i'm just so
tired the world revolves around him and
if it doesn't he just blows it to hell
it has to stop can't stop greatness
i know how to make both our lives easier
we are insane it's
not a are gonna change
[Music]
crap those are f oh my god i just swear
f is so much worse
what happened baby i'm so sorry i found
them flushing these
do you want me to get you a toothbrush
or a toilet paper i'm doing a summer
camp maybe i'm going to jail
i don't know what is our online banking
password maybe i'm not going to yell
that on the street
happy new year i think i called my mom
she said you and sean can move over
there with her and trish hello
hey hey are you staying
i'm gonna figure it out i can't survive
too many days with your sister i just
brought a new girl
hey girl why are you so naked all the
time wearing pants in the house is
stupid okay i feel
liberated i want to feel free at home
what well how you feel at work then
expensive
killing my voice i could ever oh my god
i kicked my mom pleading guilty is
terrible legal advice
you gotta say yourself don't admit to
nothing kid
you are 32 year old baby daddy in jail
who almost got her pockets ran until i
put you on my credits
yeah you real grown ash
i miss him does he know where i am man
we had an
understanding we would weather whatever
storm came along you don't get to doubt
my loyalty
you can talk to me about whatever
and we moms get to keep our secrets
right
let's go it's show time honey let me
remind you
you don't know these people know your
place
stick with me and i'll guide you i know
something i'm not allowed to feel
welcome to the ordeal let's turn up on
this down
get off the couch get moving get ready
please shimmy
vamanos muchacho we gotta go
frogs okay i'm ready where are we going
again
i don't swim oh yeah
it's an adult swim party let's go
[Music]
now
[Music]
he's
[Applause]
don't you wanna meet the guy behind
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
wow hey just the wrong truck it's better
ones across the street bro
okay let's wiggle
they have a code red situation
in half an hour we could be looking at
another chern novel i just couldn't get
through the first series to be honest
it's a national emergency jerry
no no it's me i said you only got my
drinks might be on the wall
yeah i'm down i'll call you back
half a million lives all at stake what
oh god it's endless isn't it
we have 25 minutes more pressing than
that i've got a date tonight
what's that noise are you eating soup
we're kissing i know i'd love to take a
crack at saving the whole world
not just this little island wow
yes well someone's got to be the hero
how good is your american accent really
not very good ma'am
[Music]
only you have the power to change you
let's do this thing
[Music]
today you will eat clean healthy foods
after school drop off you will go
directly to ballet class
i will have a nice day babe the coffee
slowly
clean healthy food three famous
cheeseburgers three large fries and a
chocolate shake
thanks after school drop-off i will go
to ballet class
it's closed i will have a nice day
professor rubin is getting fired
we're gonna need money i love you
whatever happens you think something bad
will happen
no you're trusting this ding dong with
your life
what's up lady sorry
you ready to do this thing now you've
done it she sees what mess you are
actually i feel better than i have been
in a long time where are you going
i've been doing aerobics classes you
should check it you might like it
and after just one class you can feel it
happening you becoming you again
how long can we afford to live off our
savings we're all gonna do our part
and by we he needs you you ever think of
hiring into the teacher
if you screw this up you're done here
it's kinky bottle blonde to the right
oh sorry i meant you're left i can't
keep up
blend in i feel like that constantly
i can come to your house i could teach
you aerobics there
there's a small chance it might not be a
lame business
you don't know idea i'm capable of i
built something
something solid that's all yours what
the hell is all this
no one is taking it away
don't underestimate me
go get him tiger
[Music]
rick and morty you are under arrest and
surrounded by an anti-portal
it's showtime someone out there is
trying to kill us
someone's always trying to kill him
richard sorry who is that
now what now we go
[Music]
when do i ask you for anything when do
you i haven't been to a full week of
school in years i don't know
police a strange horny ocean man is on
my lawn
sweetie don't get all worked up before
your job interview job interview
yes is that so hard to believe actually
yeah something's off
all right what hide
how do we just hit buttons we're too big
to fail
time to turn up the broiler
i think it's in our best interest to
work as a team yeah most people would
call that
[Applause]
what the family it up okay it's okay
morty that's what you do
let me deus ex machina let's go home
say hello to my little me
new rick and morty starting sunday june
20th at 11 p.m
this is out there even for us they can
hear you morty only
an adult
a man's got to be accountable for what
he's done
somebody once said when the system fails
righteous men will rise up
this is the work i do every murder is
the tale
of a city give the devil or dear
because this is
you